Seth Rogen Jay Baruchel Craig Robinson
James Franco Danny McBride Jonah are all
in the same [ __ ] movie this is the
end wow that is what I got to say to
this movie it is batshit crazy yeah is
it funny yeah it's pretty [ __ ] funny
not all the time let's sort of like this
only moments make you laugh but their
moments throughout the whole entire
[ __ ] film and a lot of ways actually
loved it there is a lot of great
self-deprecating humor it's funny to see
Seth Rogen jizz bag on himself and to
see James Franco just really [ __ ] up his
image it's hilarious and this film is
also loaded with a bunch of great
hilarious cameos what I like about it
too is that what the cameos they
actually have them do something they're
not just there to be there every cameo
that is actually pretty funny for the
most part one day I really appreciate
about this movie the setup of the film
because you get so comfortable with
these characters right up front and he
get comfortable with the story and then
by the time the apocalypse thing happens
you kind of almost forgot about it a lot
of these apocalyptic movies try to
establish some type of serious heavy
hitting tone but to me this is probably
what the apocalypse might actually feel
like you're just having a normal day and
then BAM something [ __ ] crazy happens
I imagine on the day of the apocalypse
I'm probably gonna be sucking ryan
gosling's dick and then when he comes
[ __ ] dragon in the sky another thing
too is this film is actually scary at
times what's cool is it's not just a
comedy about the apocalypse it is in a
POC elliptic movie that also happens to
be a comedy like I said this film is
batshit crazy it is absolutely nuts some
of the most disgusting things happen in
this film and I'm telling you right now
you're gonna be offended I don't care
who you are how successful you are how
much respect you have there's something
in this film that is guaranteed to
offend you like oh my god I cannot
believe they're able to get away with
making a whole bit about this one topic
but I'd say this one has a hard
r rating I mean this is an r-rated movie
that has a hard erection I'm telling you
right now man I cannot stop talking
about penises this movie tells a lot of
penises in them they talk a lot about
penises and a lot about what penises can
do james franco has a giant sculpture of
a penis apparently these really famous
people love the penis a lot let me get
straight to the point here all in all I
gotta say this is the end got it right
all right guys check it out my chair
once you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell me what is your
favorite movie starring one of these
guys you got a lot of choices but tell
me which one is your favorite and if you
want to see a more in-depth review of
this is the end go ahead and check out
my so-called reasons to see that I do
with my buddy Jerry well we'll give you
a breakdown of reasons to see this is
the end and last one at least if you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out go ahead and subscribe to
my channel by clicking on the link by my
penis that's right penis Scarface's
penis